>> I DON'T WANT TO HAVE A DUNK I
NEED TO SEE THE REWIND ON.
I WANT TO BE OOH AND AHHED.
>> YOU WANT TO BE MORE -- YOU
WANT TO BE FLOORED.
>> I WANT TO BE FLOORED.
>> AT LEAST D-WADE IS NOT
INVOLVED IN ANY JUDGING
DECISIONS THIS TIME AROUND, SO
WE ARE IN GOOD SHAPE.
OBI TOPPIN.
>> ALL I'LL SAY IS KARL-ANTHONY
TOWNS HAD 29 IN THE FINAL ROUND.
THIS PLACE WAS ELECTRIC.
>> MAN, THIS DUNK CONTEST WAS A
SIX!
>> MAN, IS THERE A FIVE?
>> A SIX!
>> I TELL YOU WHAT.
WE ALWAYS HAVE -- WE HAVE AN OFF
YEAR.
EVEN LeBRON JAMES HAS OFF GAMES.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> OBI TOPPIN WINS THE AT&T SLAM
DUNK COMPETITION.
YOU BROUGHT --
>> SIX OUT OF NINE.
>> YOU BROUGHT YOUR OWN --
>> HOW ABOUT A FLIP IT.
>> THIS DUNK CONTEST RIGHT HERE
WAS A SOLID SIX.
>> WAH-WAH-WAH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DON'T MESS MY DUNK CONTEST UP.
>> COME ON, KENNY.
THAT W